et cette essais nucléaire réalisé grâce
selon Pyongyang à une technologie 100%
nord-coréenne souligne un peu plus le
décalage entre le pouvoir mégalomaniaque
des dirigeants et une population dont
une grande partie estime le Programme
alimentaire mondial meurt de faim
Alexandra Marie
le dictateur Kim jong- Il face à une
parade militaire voici une des rares
images autorisées de la Corée du Nord un
régime stalinien pur et dur fondé sur la
propagande et le culte de la
personnalité partout dans les rues de
Pyongyang des statues monumentales à son
effigie et à celle de son père qui
illzung à qui il a succédé il y a 12 ans
son règne a fait de la Corée un des pays
les plus fermés au monde en l'absence de
journalistes et d'observateurs
internationaux les 22 millions de
Nord-Coréens n'ont liberté de
déplacement ni liberté d'expression
selon Amnesty International il serait
même de plus en plus nombreux à vouloir
fuir car depuis plus de 10 ans le pays
doit faire face à une véritable
catastrophe humanitaire le régime mène
une politique de militarisation à
outrance au détriment du développement
agricole résultat depuis plus de 10 ans
le pays est en proie à une crise
alimentaire très grave et même les ONG
ont des difficultés à entrer dans le
pays
pour le Programme alimentaire mondial de
ne pas pouvoir assister des personnes
dont nous savons qu'elles ont besoin
d'aide le gouvernement persiste à dire
qu'il va s'occuper d'eux et j'espère que
c'est vrai mais depuis l'an dernier nous
savons que beaucoup de gens ont besoin
de nous
selon les rares témoins près de 40% des
enfants
soufflaient de malnutrition
l'année
le Pass à l'aide de ces rares
partenaires régionaux mais en défiant
aujourd'hui la communauté internationale
la Corée du Nord s'est exposée à des
sanctions qui ne feront qu'aggraver la
situation du pays